en attendant la bataille des primaires
écolos eva joly s'expose enfin la
candidate à la présidentielle change de
zera tj médiatique discrète jusque là la
voilà partie à l'assaut des plateaux
télé un changement de pied en termes de
communication qu'elle reconnaît bien
volontiers
on ne peut pas simplement travailler
faire des déficits il faut aussi faire
savoir
et en fait ça fait partie du jeu donc
chez t'excite effectivement un
communiqué faire du bruit pour contrer
le silence du moment celui de nicolas
hulot ira ira pas la présidentielle il
réfléchit il conçut le dit son entourage
mais au sein d'europe écologie les verts
en tout cas il à ses supporters qui le
pressent de se découvrir c'est le cas
d'yves cochet candidat à la primaire
écolo mais impatients de lui laisser la
place moi j'ai toujours dit que si
nicolas lau disait publiquement qu'il
était candidat écologiste à la
présidentielle je me retirais de ces
primaires
je pense qu'ils font ils auront il a
rencontré aussi madame eva joly est plus
du tout et voir également même genre
d'accord entre eux pas encore parce que
lui n'est pas encore candidat mais je
souhaite qu'il se décide dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent une
candidature virtuelle gênante pour la
direction d'europe écologie et verts
parce qu en attendant l'issue de ce
débat
le message de l'écologie politique est
brouillée si l'on y va il devra rendre
des comptes dans ce parti ancré à gauche
europe ecologie les verts sont pas
pétrifié mamba tout arrêter en attendant
you donc si à nicholas tse décidé d
à l'occasion de cette primaire il ne
dise ce qu'il compterait faire s'il est
sélectionné ce qu'il comptera fer entre
le 1er et le 2ème tour parce que pour
nous il n'est pas question de dire ah le
soir du premier tour de refaire le coup
du ni droite ni gauche
ce dimanche on connaîtra les dates des
primaires d'europe écologie les verts
organisé à priori avant l'été et d'ici
là nicolas hulot devrait enfin sortir du
bois